you know you've done so well and you've
got to reflect sometimes about
man it's gone so well for me and then
the humble beginnings you moved out to
la when you were
how old was 17 17 years old
to get started in the business yeah in
time yeah 17 i drove out uh with my mom
and my
1982 toyota corolla um it was great
mm-hmm yeah and that's the story from
where where are we
from uh from idaho from idaho wow that
is a classic
story next to getting off the bus with a
cardboard suitcase and going like
wow wow yeah i always knew i wanted to
be an actor from a very young age and
i moved out uh my first place was this
very small studio apartment
i had five thousand dollars my to my
name um it was 500 bucks a month
i quickly had to have a roommate move in
um
big enough for a roommate no i uh i
i shared with him one week i'd have the
bed and the next week i would live in
the
walk-in closet really yeah it's true
so okay that was nice that you worked
out an arrangement so one of you would
get the bed and one of you would pretty
much just hide in a closet
yeah just when you know it was time to
go to sleep it was it was nice it was
roomy it was dark
yeah yeah no it doesn't there's nothing
you can say that's going to make it
sound appealing
it's a pretty good decision but the rent
was only 250 bucks a month it was right
great 250 a month yeah it's pretty good
yeah should have split at 60 40 and just
someone move into the closet
yeah and just pay the 40 i actually
didn't mind the closet but
our bed was in the kitchen like it was
right next to the
like the kitchen wait so if someone's in
the kitchen making food
yeah your bed was there was a bit of
where and someone's asleep or kind of
waking up
listening to that person sometimes you'd
prefer the closet yeah
yeah and you can't have anyone you also
can't have like a guest come over and
say hey give me some privacy do you know
what i mean that's really possible
yeah that's indirect could you please
just get in your closet yeah
yeah shut the door like it's it's your
week in the closet not mine
yeah it's pretty great